the point of the rally
is to number one protect
this statue because
this statue is one of many statues
that are in honor of the history of
western civilization and european
peoples that are being torn down
[Applause]
the policies that liberals have put in
place although
they may have been put in place with
good intentions
are effectively ethnically cleansing
white people from the face of the earth
one of the ethnicities that's most in
danger is
the southern white people
[Music]
hey get
i don't think that people should be
treated unfairly
because of their race or any other
characteristic
i just feel like this country and its
demographic
should remain the same as they have been
for
the majority of their history but there
seems to be this problem with the social
justice people
where they have a distinct hatred for
white people
some might say they're they're pushing
for equality
no i would not say that they're pushing
for equal rights i think that they have
long since
passed the point where they have
been going for anything approximating
equality
they're looking for special treatment
for these groups at this point
they want to have institutionalized
discrimination against white people they
refuse to accept
that there are genetic differences
between different
races of people so there are reasons why
for instance
asians jews and white people are
people who have high test scores and are
able to compete
in a university environment
i do think that the country should be 80
to 85 percent white because
that was the traditional demographic of
the country it was white people who
founded this country
and it is our race which is
in danger of being eradicated due to
these
immigration policies
women's best role
in life is to be mothers and to be wives
in your view i shouldn't be working i
shouldn't be talking to you
in this no i didn't professional setting
no i didn't say that people should be
banned from
having professions but i think that
culturally we should put
an emphasis on uh having
women as wives and mothers
are you worried about violence erupting
on saturday
[Music]
my role as a pastor a grassroots
organizer a father
is to call on people to stand up
in the face of evil and stand up for
what is good i
as part of the team that put out a call
for 1 000 clergy and faith leaders to
join us in body and spirit
and we're just one piece of the movement
of
community members that are coming to
sherman's
i can still remember standing on the
street
on the sidewalk and watching the clan
rally go by
i can still remember the flags the
american flag being one of them and the
hoods
passing me by i can still see it in my
mind's eye
and here i am at 54 years old
coming back because the clan is still
rising up
this is our state nazis are not welcome
here
nazis arnold welcome
[Music]
it's pretty amazing there was this
incredible interfaith
service here at the episcopal church in
charlottesville and now just across
lockdown yes the road
is hundreds of alt-right people
carrying torches and no one really knows
where they're going
whether they're coming in this direction
a lot of people are sort of
locked down in the church it's so
bizarre it's like
the civil rights era all over again
can you see the rights
you will not replace us
you will not replace us you
no fascists no kkk you're the only sad
one
your america's gone [ __ ] how do
you how do you feel good about
yourselves just [ __ ] standing there
like that
by yourself because i'm losing
broadcasting
this to all my friends and showing them
how sad and pathetic you are
where are your jobs right there's
nothing wrong with being proud of who
you are
[Applause]
[Music]
our country has been usurped by a
foreign tribe
called the jews are you in charge
the blacks are the blacks
[Music]
now an unlawful assembly disperse the
area
unless
[Music]
around me
[Music]
we must never allow anybody to
naturalize
criminality to make crimes look like
it's
part of the natural order
[Music]
we shall
[Music]
no fear white supremacy is not welcome
here no hate
no fear
[Applause]
the commanding officer of the
pennsylvania left foot militia
all these militiamen summer militias
some are three quarterback three
percenters uh some of his pastries
they just come out here to make sure
that uh things kind of stay peaceful
you know a lot of these rallies and
stuff that are happening lately
law enforcement's greatly outcome
we came out here we're loud and proud
we're not going anywhere
we're an american organization and uh
our membership represents this
[Applause]
let's go
we have already
[Applause]
okay
sir you wanted free speech
that you want to talk would you like to
talk
no have you been instructed not to talk
to the media
why did you want
can you talk about why you wanted to be
here are you with the press
yeah no comment why excuse me
step aside i don't just step aside i can
stand wherever i want
don't tell me to step aside
[Music]
hey
well they had they had riot gear and
they charged us is what happened
i don't i don't know haven't looked in
the mirror
[Music]
i just got [ __ ] dumped on me look at me
my brand new shirt
would you consider yourself a neo-nazi i
would not i'd consider myself a white
nationalist and i would consider myself
a member of the alt-right
and what does that mean to you white
nationalist i want a homeland for white
people and i think every race should
have a homeland for their own race
so do you agree that uh with the guy who
organizes
organizes jason kessler that america
should be 80 to 85
white yes and and why
i think there's a demographic decline
going on not only here but in europe and
we need some place that can be a white
homeland where we will be
spread out and how old are you 18. do
your parents agree with you
no not at all my mother is a union
teacher and my father is a blue collar
worker
no they don't agree with me at all how
do they feel about your being here
my mom and my father most heavily
discouraged i think all of our parents
did actually
following your parents beliefs just
because they're older than you and they
raised you
it doesn't mean it's it's it's not a
good idea you should believe for
yourself you should look into things for
yourself and then decide what you want
where did my family come from um both
grandparents on my side of me or
grandparents or italian immigrants
we came together for this this rally so
i would say that
i might disagree with their optics or
their appearance or whatever they have
declared
i have to go
us
okay
see we're marching to mcintyre we're
marching to mcintyre park
charlottesville police department comes
in an hour and a half after our permit
started at 10 a.m
and declares an unlawful assembly it was
a heckler's veto
we our people were not being violent
they were being violent to us
and from my understanding our people
were tear gas
after they declared an unlawful assembly
our people left
immediately and they still
i didn't witness that but that's what
people are telling me
[Applause]
somewhere
what did you think of what you saw today
here in charlottesville
i've never seen so much hatred in the
eyes of my fellow human beings in my
life
we are in very deep trouble this country
is
in deep trouble you've been doing this
kind of activism for a long time and
how would you compare this to other
moments in history
well this is a neo-fascist moment and
it's a neo-fascism that is
much broadly spread than it was before
i'm against hatred and so when i hear
that anarchist brothers and sisters talk
about scum i don't like that language
but they're responding to a hatred that
is so
vicious and they're not they're not
running anything and they're not tied to
anything you know
the goal of one side is domination
oppression and separation the goal of
the other side
is more democracy is acceptance
is toxic i don't like the way they're
expressing that because it comes out as
hatred
but you have to differentiate between
the two sides because of the goals
the goal of one side is oppression the
goal of the other side is freedom
even though we might not agree with
their tactics
you have to differentiate between the
two
go go
[Music]
12
and they got out here
[Music]
no i need my sister okay they're gonna
get her in the ambulance right now
[Applause]
what we gathered it was injuries
one fatality from a vehicle plowing into
a crowd of people
i'm not sure what ever was about the
statue this is just about reprehensible
racism
that's all that it is
this is just the beginning of heather's
legacy
they tried to kill my child to shut her
up well
guess what you just magnified here
[Music]